Not only do chromosomal translocations happen, not only
can you swap genetic information actual genes in
frame to get fusion proteins, but there are
certain kinds of translocations that are known to happen
on a regular basis. A very famous one
that results in something called the Philadelphia chromosome is
actually chromosomal translocation between chromosomes 9 and chromosomes
22. There is a gene in chromosome 22 called
BCR, and another gene on chromosome 9 called A B L or ABL. What happens
is the tip of chromosome 9 here can actually break off, and this end from
here down on chromosome 22 can get
broken off, and these pieces get swapped. This
large chunk here gets put at the end of chromosome 9. So if I highlight this
here, it's now down here. And this tiny region, ABL is over here. So the gene
ABL was the edge of the breaking point, and the gene BCR was the edge of the
breaking point. And now the ABL and BCR genes are right here next to each other,
and they produce a fusion protein called BCR-ABL.
As you can imagine this fusion protein is abnormal
activity, and the result is a form of blood cancer called chronic
myelogenous leukemia or CML. Amazingly, there's a drug that can
inhibit this unique protein and treat patients suffering from this chromosomal
aberration. Scientists brought us a long ways people. This is pretty cool.